hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Psychological
Thriller film called Gone Girl spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
Nicholas Nick Dunn is a nonchalant man
in his 40s who has been married to a
beautiful wife named Amy today is the
fifth anniversary of their wedding but
unlike other husbands Nick seems to be
quite off it's evident that he has lost
interest in his wife instead of buying a
gift for her he heads to the bar to have
some drinks the bartender is none other
than his twin sister Margot she notices
Nick's hung up face and inquires about
the reason he simply says Amy and the
movie goes into a flashback to the night
they met Amy a popular children's writer
had organized a book launch event and
Nick was among the several attendees the
two met coincidentally and started
conversing about their shared interest
in books Nick was a writer himself but
only for a small men's magazine while
Amy was adored by millions like if the
writer of The Hunger Games met the
writer of seven cool ways to trim your
pubes soon they went outside and
wandered around the alleys of New York
City Nick had used his charm and good
looks to impress Amy and at an opportune
moment he kissed her they capped off
their Night by making passionate love in
the present as Nick continues explaining
his story he suddenly gets a call from
his neighbor saying that his cat is
outside Nick hurries home and retrieves
the cat strangely the front door is open
Nick calls out for Amy but she does not
respond so he searches around the house
until he comes across a shattered glass
table this surprises Nick so he
immediately calls for help shortly after
detective Rhonda arrives at the scene
with her assistant and quickly gets to
work she scans through the house and
finds a few droplets of blood in unusual
places then she observes Amy's room and
comes across her books realizing that
she is a famous writer detective Rhonda
starts treating her disappearance as a
high profile case later all of them
arrive at the police station and Nick is
asked to go through a few tasks once
he's done detective Ronda assures him
that they will find Amy her credit cards
are being tracked a forensics team is
already on the crime scene to check for
Clues and most importantly a press
conference will be held to tomorrow to
appeal for help strangely Nick finds all
of this funny and he even compares it to
the show Law and Order this is the first
red flag for detective Ronda so she
starts asking him questions however Nick
can't answer many of them like he
doesn't know Amy's blood type her
favorite food or even her nickname all
Nick knows is that Amy had no friends
and she spent most of her time reading
books following this we are again taken
to a flashback it is the first
anniversary of Nick and Amy's marriage
and they are living happily they often
have coitus in public places and gift
each other with expensive items but
little did they know that their lives
are only going downhill from this point
onwards I don't know any couple should
know that they've peaked once they've
scratched banging in the ball pit at a
McDonald's off their list back in the
present as detective Rhonda is looking
for Clues at the crime scene a pregnant
woman named Noel shows up claiming to be
Amy's best friend she reveals that she
lives just three blocks away and has
been in close proximity with Amy for
over a year this makes Rhonda suspect
vicious as previously Nick mentioned
that his wife didn't have any friends
nonetheless she decides to interrogate
Noel later and sends her away following
this she enters the Dunn residence and
learns from the forensic team that the
kitchen floor was splattered with blood
which was then later cleaned furthermore
it is revealed that the entire house is
registered in Amy's name the next day
the scheduled press conference takes
place since Amy is a popular writer
hundreds of reporters have arrived and
the whole thing is being broadcasted
live on television Nick and his in-laws
are set to take over the press
conference when it's next turn he
reluctantly utters two sentences and
even puts on a smile for a photograph
that night he heads to his father's
abandoned house to relax just then
detective Ronda arrives and it turns out
that she was following him this enrages
Nick so he quickly escorts her out of
the house before departing in his car
next another flashback is shown where
the couple has started going through a
rough patch now Amy records everything
in her diary the couple is shifted to
Nick's Hometown in Missouri to look
after his terminally ill mother it has
already been a few months but Nick has
yet to find a job this forces Amy to
borrow money from her wealthy parents
things are running on a very tight
budget but Nick who is not used to being
unemployed recklessly spends money on
video games oh no what a loose cannon
Amy tries to encourage him that better
days will come but it appears as if all
their conversations results in arguments
in the present it has been two days
since Amy's disappearance her parents
have organized an event to attract more
Helping Hands and are doing everything
to find their daughter Nick however is
nonchalant as always he even clicks a
few selfies with the attendees that
night Nick decides to stay at his sister
marga's place to avoid the swarm of
Paparazzi that have been encircling him
unfortunately even there he has no
respite on the television Margot sees
several news channels reporting about
Nick's Carefree attitude some even
question if he is sad at all so Margo
confronts her brother about the same
thing and Nick angrily replies that he
wasn't expecting this from her the past
few days have been a nightmare for him
so he just wants a good night's sleep
without being judged hearing this Margot
apologizes and goes to sleep after a few
hours surprisingly a young girl enters
the house and jumps into Nick's arms she
is revealed to be his girlfriend Andy
this apparently clarifies everything
Nick doesn't care about his wife's
disappearance because he is in love with
someone else but that leaves the big
question is he responsible for it
meanwhile the two get physical and spend
the night together unfortunately the
next morning Margot catches her brother
in the act and chastises him for hiding
things from her but Nick quickly
retaliates by explaining how miserable
Amy made him feel at one point she
stopped caring for him and spending even
a single day had become difficult that's
why he had to find solace in someone
else and that someone turned out to be
one of his students Andy shocked Margot
warns her brother that if the
authorities find out about this he is in
trouble she also shows Nick that he is
all over the news but for the wrong
reasons in another flashback through
Amy's diary it has shown that she wanted
to have a child with Nick hoping it
would solve their ongoing problems
however Nick was completely against the
idea in a resulting argument he pushed
her to the floor accidentally hurting
her although Nick apologized profusely
for it Amy had reached her breaking
point and from that day onwards she
started fearing for her life and wanted
a divorce however she knew that Nick
wouldn't leave her as he wanted her
parents money in the present detective
Rhonda gets the forensics report of the
blood samples around the house it
belongs to none other than Amy at night
Nick is asked to give another speech to
a mass of people but just then Amy's
supposed best friend Noel pops up and
screams that he is hiding things after
she has the crowd's attention she
reveals that Amy was actually six weeks
pregnant at the time of her
disappearance hearing this Margot Andy
Abby's parents everyone is shocked the
crowd also turns against Nick but
fortunately he is escorted Away by the
police that night as Nick is drinking at
home detective Rhonda confronts him with
a set of photographs which show that Amy
and Noel were indeed good friends she
also tells them that the blood inside
the kitchen belongs to his wife finally
detective Rhonda comes to the conclusion
that Amy was murdered she only needs the
dead body to confirm her Theory and put
Nick Behind Bars she left at the most
damning evidence of all Nick plays video
games after she is gone Margot
approaches her distressed brother and
asks him about Amy's pregnancy
surprisingly Nick reveals that he never
knew about it in fact Amy never wanted
to have a baby wait but that's not what
we saw but hmm at the same time
detective Ronda reaches Nick's father's
house to look for Clues she does not
find a body but she finds Amy's half
burnt diary in the furnace following
this we are taken to the day of The
Disappearance in a shocking turn of
events it is revealed that Amy herself
is the perpetrator of the entire
incident everything that is pointing
towards her husband's arrest was
meticulously planned by her in Amy's
Eyes Nick took her soul by lying to her
cheating on her and taking away her
pride and money we are then shown how
she staged the whole thing at first she
secretly befriended the dumbest neighbor
in the area and invited her home knowing
that Noel was pregnant Amy cunningly
stole her urine sample and took it to a
local hospital to create fake medical
records she also filled noelle's mind
with lies about how Nick beats her up
every night as for the crime scene Amy
drew two bags of blood from her hand and
splattered it across the kitchen floor
she then swept it carelessly so that the
police could find traces of it finally
Amy wrote fake stories in her diary and
left it for the cops this means that
Nick never assaulted her in fact she was
the aggressive one as Amy drives away in
her car she reveals that she started
planning the night she saw Nick cheating
on her elsewhere Nick has also become
sure that his wife is trying to frame
him but since he has no proof he decides
to visit Tanner the smartest lawyer in
the country Tanner immediately showcases
his quick thinking skills by advising
Nick on a few things if he wants to win
the case firstly he has just to make
sure the country is on his side for that
he has to defame Amy Tanner says that
the first step would be to find someone
she screwed over in the past and get a
testimony from them Nick knows just the
perfect guy before him Amy was in a
relationship with Desi Collings a rich
guy from New York the two were a perfect
match because of their high standards
but soon Desi became possessive this
resulted in their breakup and when Desi
still didn't stop pursuing Amy she had
to file a restraining order against him
but to this day he still writes letters
to her Nick uses the address from one of
these letters and visits his Mansion but
unfortunately Desi doesn't want to speak
badly about the love of his life despite
everything that Amy has done to him he
still wants to defend her on the other
hand Amy has completely changed her
identity and is now living in a small
neighborhood she mostly minds her own
business and tries to stay away from
everyone around however one day she
accidentally drops her thick wad of
money which a few of her neighbors
notice that night she is attacked by the
same people who beat her up and take the
money away the only good thing is that
they didn't realize she is the Gone Girl
from the news but Amy doesn't want to
take the chance so she packs her
belongings and leaves the place she
doesn't have a place to stay so she
calls the only person who loves her
unconditionally Desi callings in the
next scene if the two meet in a casino
and Amy quickly starts manipulating him
she lies that she was forced to run away
from her home as Nick was about to kill
her now she cannot return as the entire
nation will perceive her as a coward
Desi immediately buys her story and
takes this as the perfect opportunity to
reconcile with her hence he escorts Amy
to his private villa which lies in the
middle of nowhere there are cameras
around the entire place so Amy won't
have to worry about being discovered
elsewhere after the first plan fails
Tanner tells Nick to go live on
television and confess about his illicit
Affair this will gain him a lot of
sympathy as Everyone likes an honest man
but does everyone like an honest
cheating piece of [ __ ] man I don't know
unfortunately on the interview you day
they get a major shock Nick's girlfriend
Andy breaks the news herself this leaves
Nick in a perilous position Tanner
explains that now they are on the back
foot so going live on television would
be a Death Wish however Nick reassures
him that he can handle it then he goes
on the interview set puts on a serious
face and delivers an emotional
confession although many believe that he
is Faking It Amy who is watching from
The Villa is impressed she is especially
touched when Nick mentions I will love
my wife forever now 21 days after her
disappearance which has caused a
nationwide uproar Amy is thinking of
returning back to her husband however
there is one problem Desi is really
expecting her to be his wife he has even
left his personal life and isolated
himself in the Villa with her Amy knows
that if she tries to leave he will
become violent and do something drastic
hence she decides to kill two birds with
one stone At first she goes inside the
bathroom the only place that there are
no cameras then she leaves rope marks on
her rests to make it look like she had
been tied up for the second step she
scars her private organs and goes near
one of the cameras to record herself
screaming later when Desi arrives home
she seduces him to make out with her as
he is distracted Amy finishes him off
brutally that was legend wait for it
oh he died elsewhere things are looking
Grim for Nick as detective Rhonda has
gone through the entire diary and is on
the verge of arresting him but one
morning Everything Changes Amy arrives
outside the house still covered in
Desi's blood this changes the whole
complexion of the case Nick who is
America's most hated man a while ago is
now innocent in the evening the doctors
examine Amy and conclude that she was
mistreated Nick knows that she is once
again deceiving everyone but he has no
evidence to prove it later in front of a
number of officials Amy tells her BS
story she explains how her possessive
boyfriend Desi kidnapped her and held
her hostage for several weeks the news
goes viral and once again Amy becomes
the sweetheart of America except for
Nick and his sister Margo everyone
believes her sob story in the final
scene the couple returns back to their
home and the drama is over in Nick's
eyes Amy is a murderer but the latter
explains that she did everything to get
back to him however with everything that
has happened Nick is afraid to live with
her he tells her that he's leaving but
Amy threatens to ruin his life if he
even considers doing so hearing this
Nick realizes that he is trapped with
this lunatic forever the movie ends as
he puts Amy to sleep and locks the door
from outside indicating that he doesn't
feel safe in his house anymore subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching